hundreds of meters underground
large enough to house tens to hundreds
of
thousands of people and walls
strong enough to withstand the force of
a nuclear blast
these are some of the world's deepest
and largest
bunkers but even in an apocalypse
you wouldn't be completely safe in one
of these
earth-penetrating weapons like the 1.2
megaton b83 warhead can demolish
bunkers 300 meters deep
what would it take to build a deeper
bunker
what would life be like inside it
and why can living underground
be dangerous this is what if
and here's what would happen if we built
the world's
deepest bunker
the deepest hole in the world the cola
super deep borehole
penetrates about 12 kilometers deep into
the earth's surface
in comparison underground bunkers are
usually built at
much shallower depths one of the deepest
bunkers in the world
the cheyenne mountain complex is only
about 610
meters deep so what's the problem
if we can dig thousands of meters into
the earth what's stopping us from
making a bunker just as deep
the truth is we do have the tools and
technology to build the world's deepest
bunker
the only other things we'd need are lots
of time
and money lots and lots of money
as we dig deeper and deeper the soil
pressure will continue to increase
it'll become expensive and difficult to
keep the hole
from collapsing in on itself we could
use
sheet pile walls to support the soil
pressure
they're commonly used in construction
and excavation but
the deeper we dig the harder it is to
construct the walls
another way we could work around this is
to dig
narrower and narrower as we reach the
bottom of the hole
it would look similar to an open pit
mine
the soil would be stable without the
need of any support
then all that's left is to build the
bunker right in the middle of the hole
and fill it back up afterwards sure
it'll be safer but
ridiculously pricey and time-consuming
some of the most expensive bunkers cost
millions of dollars to build so it's
safe to say
that building the deepest bunker could
easily
cost a fortune but what if we had the
money and resources to build the bunker
what would life be like if we had to
stay down here
now don't be expecting a five-star bed
and breakfast
you'll be surrounded by thick tightly
sealed
concrete walls so no gas water or
radiation can get through and before you
get settled in
you'll need to make sure that the bunker
has a reliable power source underground
a good filtration system and an ample
supply
of food and water the food down below in
the bunker
wouldn't be much different than what
astronauts eat up above
your diet would consist of dehydrated or
freeze-dried foods to prevent
spoilage and to save space that is
until hydroponic farms can be built this
is what farming could look like in an
underground bunker
instead of soil and sunlight some
hydroponic farms use
nutrient-rich water and artificial light
to grow plants
not only that but by using aquaponics
fish and plants can be farmed together
even indoors eating fish can help
provide us with an essential nutrient
that will
definitely be lacking underground
vitamin d
sadly if you're living underground you
won't be able to get
under the sun and work on your tan but
there are
much bigger problems you're going to
have to worry about
most of the vitamin d we get is from the
sun
we need this vitamin to keep our bones
strong and healthy
ultraviolet a and ultraviolet b rays
from the sun are also essential so that
we can make
vitamin b in our bodies it helps boost
our immune system
and it keeps us happy and energized
a lack of sunlight can cause other
health problems too
it can cause seasonal affective disorder
a type of depression
that occurs in fall and winter when
there's less light
the sun also helps to keep our circadian
rhythm in check it's the body's
internal clock and helps to regulate our
sleep patterns
without the sun people in isolation have
slept
as much as 48 hours at a time
maybe we could use led lamps to provide
artificial sunlight
and a diet with a lot of vitamin d rich
foods
okay now that everyone has enough food
and light
there's one more important thing that
we'll need to take care of
the community with everyone's lives
confined to the bunker staying connected
will be
ever so important you'll need to rely on
other people as you adapt to this new
lifestyle
creating a normal life in the bunker
where kids go to school
adults go to work and each person has
their own room
can help everyone adjust building the
world's deepest bunker might
keep you safe from what's happening on
the surface but
making sure everyone is healthy
underground is
just as important all right now that you
know what it would be like
in the world's deepest bunker what if we
built the world's
tallest tower one that reached outer
space
well that's a story for another
what if
you